le reportage qui suit contient des cinq
qui pourraient vous surprendre
nous préférons vous en aviser
[Musique]
commence à
celui ci on trouve ça s'anime l
argile il s'agit des couilles du mouton
quoi ya pas à sortir de là est-ce que
c'est l'internet sa bourse oui ça c'est
l'italien de sable abondant et ça a été
du livre et ça c'était bouillir on
inculque aux jeunes et oui bon ça peut
faire braiser on ferait pas comme champ
non
[Musique]
content de ce qu'on a trouvé aujourd'hui
ça fait de la laitue de mer sacrifiant
la nourriture est une des façons les
plus naturels et enrichissante de
s'initier à d'autres cultures le mollet
poblano est une tradition au mexique
c'est le plan des mariages ou est ce pas
besoin d'attendre une fête pour déguster
et
voilà tout ça il fait à partir d'un
panier en bambou très beaux
lots ni guide les travailleurs du
quartier n'ont vraiment adoptés est ce
que vous avez dit maintenant triangle
montré moins beau mais non ya pas de
triangle
on l'attrapé d'un temps bien plus rapide
c'est véhiculé en eau va mieux
c'est page et la fille ne
sait pas comment la pizza là pour nous
faire manger lamalgue anita donc
monsieur les couleurs de l'état les
jours et joue ben laden inquiète de ce
goûter
moi j'ai commencé
on dit aussi deux en attendant
qu'est ce que c'est en chinois tianhe
tôt mais en france et a de quoi être en
colère dont
vient de ces produits qui nous intrigue
qu'on voudrait acheter mais qu'on sait
pas vraiment quoi en faire notre produit
vedette cette semaine la fleur de
courgette zaatar c'est un classique de
la cuisine du moyen orient il s'agit de
la baie d'argousier les litchis chevelu
voici la nef le et la poule des bois il
s'agit de la chaire immole notre produit
vedette cette semaine ce sont des coeurs
de queneau et
les kiwis de sibérie c'est plus cher que
les kiwis mais pas mal moins poilu le
plus gros fruits au monde les actifs bon
le visuellement sur sa même grosse pomme
de terre avec une poudre et il parlait
du verre au brun selon le degré de
mûrissement il ya vraiment une d'art
très désagréable ça sans bobo
[Musique]